hey welcome back to Wolfram tech
conference I'm Jesse I'm sitting here
with developers and other interesting
people using our technology
I'm here with Etienne right now can you
tell us a little bit about what you do
here firm and sort of what your focus is
on I so so I'm working on I'm the
manager of machine learning team and so
we're developing machine learning
function follower from language that's
our main main job and so there's several
type of functions some are tools for
people to build their own machine
learning application such as highly
automated tools just classify predict so
here the idea is to be able to train a
model without much input from the user
like you define the task you get the
data and it creates a model basically
then we also have more low-level type of
tools such as neural network framework
well you can play more with with the
model to do exactly what you want and
and and then we use these tools to
create applications so much learning
applications that then we put in a
system so example I mean the first one
we did almost three years ago now has
imagine densify and we did many more
since then probably the latest is a
speech-to-text so that's that's kind of
what we do create tool and use this tool
to create applications so for those of
us who were not with me last year I
talked to Ed Tian as a previous tech
conference and I guess a lot has changed
in the machine learning framework and
from language since then so can you tell
me a little bit about what has changed
since the last time I spoke so this is
the last time I remember well we were
just automating for the automatic
function yeah we talked about automated
data scientists exactly exactly and so
we've been we've been continuing in this
direction improving a bit automation
adding new methods what one one new
model will be excited about is so you
know been automating mesh learning with
with classic algorithms you know random
forests or spoke back to machine on this
type of things and and automating it
with neural networks is a little bit
harder at least for for you know classic
data sets like that are not image or
text oh but we implemented self normally
network method that is the first type of
neural network method that works well
with you know structure like classic the
recipe
so so we're happy with that then in the
domain of automatic function big new
things for version 12 that will
hopefully be really soon is the
unsupervised learning function so so the
main function is learn distribution
whose goal is to just give it a toss
okay it's not label data it's just for
example I don't know that I said you
know like a classical data set and it
will try to learn the distribution from
this data and and when you have this
description you can do many things with
it for example you can detect anomalies
because you will you will query the with
the distribution you will ask what is
the probability that you think that this
example has and it is probability slow
you will figure out something is wrong
it's not this example doesn't follow
those statistics of the other examples
or you can do things like missing
imputation meaning you have an example
in your missing values then you can
condition your distribution on the known
values and then for example sample what
could be sort of simulation what could
be the missing values so so this will be
in 12 along with Alma detection and
something we call synthesized missing
values which are direct byproduct of
having learned distribution so that was
a big thing on the automatic part and
then on the neural network part there's
been a lot of improvement in terms of
speed in terms of new layers investment
well there will be a nice attention
layer that you can do
many more things with eating tripping
transformer and networks there will be
in terms of optimization a lot a lot of
improvement like we can use HTTP you in
version 12 we also take advantage of
tensile calls which are this kind of
specialized core in nvidia cards that
use mixed precision and now it's going
to be in all counts so that's why we we
made sure that we can support that and
makes your training faster play in terms
of applications this means some new
application natural longer processing so
so we had a function called takes cases
that we had a long time ago and and we
can have refreshed it with modern
machine learning techniques and we
already detects contents so you just get
something and ask me tell me a bit
everything you can find these things so
so what do you mean you I guess we've
had text cases for a long time what do
you mean that you like refreshed it like
what did you do to it so okay so so the
first version of office versions of text
cases when mainly using or you say the
semantics the Spelling's that that we
created with Wolfram Alpha so we have a
lot of knowledge about
let's say all the city is over country
is although not a good person you know
these sort of things and and so we use
that to kind of do a classic pattern
matching of string matching almost to
figure out what's in the text now we try
to introduce more context so by using a
neo network that we actually really read
from the text like your regular on
network that reads from the text and try
to infer let's say is the string apple
fruits or the company ok and but so this
is is a classic task of entity named
entity recognition but usually the
ignition deal with 6:8 type of entities
and but in our case we deal with I guess
almost 200 entities so we try to have
all the entities that we we created for
Wolfram Alpha and flow from language to
work in text cases so we created this
big data set and and we trained a neo
Network on that and it's working pretty
well I mean it still will experiment on
so we didn't experimental eyes a
function yet actually we have a lot of
ideas on how to create a better that I
said and train something better so I
expect that we have a lot of improvement
for this function because I believe it's
very important and I think it's one of
the most classic tasks when you have a
text to just say give me all the xxx
you mentioned a food oh yeah that's
super common I mean people go in there
control up and like look for every
mention I'm aware you know exactly this
is extension to really understand what's
in the text what ok the screen went
black here but like what what was on it
oh this was just actually an explanation
of how you could do missing imputation
using a LAN distribution okay so so for
example here so it's just a toy example
to understand what's going on so here
all the red points were the training
data and you can see here the feet that
learn distribution like we could run it
why not so so let's grab the data so
this is this is a training data okay
okay and learn distribution it's
probably the most simple automatic
function because you just leave the data
it's not annotated and just learn
distribution and okay 20 20 bit fast but
I couldn't I could show you what's going
on music information ok this is kind of
what happened it does experiments on
small data sets and then increase the
size of the other experiments in order
to figure out what is the best method
and you can see or you cannot see very
well here but there's value Smith's
multinomial distribution has interested
the other one seems to be a problem yet
Kelvin's estimation and also some
contingency table and so on whatever
kernel density estimation has been
selected so here is let's refresh this
and and here was showing an example of
synthesizing a missing value so let's
say the value was or let's let's be
let's say six point five so X is six
point five okay and Y value is missing
so the trick is to condition the
distribution on the fact that X is six
point five which means you can have cut
it here and and the value for y will be
the results will be just this this value
so it should be something between six
four and six so here we go and the
result is five point six five point five
so you see it's it's it's random which
is very useful because then you can have
an idea of the possibility for Y value
and I can actually do the Instagram so
so what is this useful for like
identifying missing missing back so it's
very classic to have missing values in
the data set and and sometimes you want
to do an analysis of the data that
requires the data has no missing values
so here you just do synthesize missing
values okay and it will put probable
values impute parabola values in data
set you can say giving sample or give is
most likely what I wanted to show is if
I put five point five
here you see it will be a ban on oil
distribution and so we should see that
in the in the histogram so this what you
will see here should be exactly so it's
the it's the you know like if you cut
distribution here slice here the section
yeah questions for you I guess do you
have anything else that you want to talk
about with the machine learning
functionality and language so I mean
there's always the question of what
we'll do next so so we've been so in the
automation style we've been kind of
pushing the boundary of what we can
automate it's a bit harder to automate
how to learn distribution than it was
for supervised learning supervised
learning it's very very forgiving you
can can extract features algorithm are
easy to compare like two models are easy
to compare with each other you can do
the processing you want you don't have
to be very careful when it's supervised
learning for learning distribution it's
a bit more problem like processing you
do has to be reversible if you have
missing values you can start mess
everything sometimes models it's hard to
compare models together because some
models they are very good to generate
samples but not very good to come to
give let's say probability
distribution so you have to figure out
how to deal with that but it's kind of
it's working out and and so now we feel
confident to continue pushing the
automation to multi output predict so
supervised learning king is where you
don't just predict you know one value or
one class but you can predict you know
arbitrary complex output n reinforcement
learning that would be I think that will
be the next the next now we kind of done
on the unsupervised learning part
there's still things we want to do and
we still have to do a little bit on
supervised learning but then we can
tackle automating run for so many it's
like I was bored I was saving that what
like reinforcement learning question for
another person okay can you explain what
reinforcement learning is to me okay so
so it's a very different type of
learning in a sense that both for
supervised and supervised learning you
give a data set a fixed data set to to
the algorithm to choose it to the
computer and they have to learn from
that
in reinforcement learning which I think
we could call more active learning even
though in in the field active learning
is a different meaning but I think it's
if it's more you have a you have an
environment which is really just a
function that you can that you can so
non very man that you can act on and get
some observation back so so it's a bit
agent of trade their own data set by
deciding to oh let's let's try this
let's try that let's you know interact
with environment and get feedback and
learn from that to solve a task so this
is
quite different paradigm two supervisors
provide and very exciting because of
application so you could learn you know
a robot to learn how to displace
themselves or in this control systems
very classic thing so we're gonna have
reinforcement learning fly all our
planes anytime soon well this I think we
can already do a completely automatic
plane travel yeah yeah these are things
that you see the boat feeling safe but I
think for planes cars much harder yeah
thank you Father
so would you personally get on a plane
when you're flying back from the
conference on a plane that was not flown
by a I would okay yeah I I guess the
other question I have I thought of a
question maybe for you with all this
automation that we have in the Wolfram
language with machine learning
functionality what's kind of the goal
that you see like what is this working
towards we can automate all of these
these things that we're not automated
before but what how do you see people
using that and what would you want them
to use all this automated features for
like who is it for like who is it
designed for and what would they do with
all of this automation well I think
by she learning problems are not
everywhere but very frequently for very
diverse range of people
anything you know in most I don't know
most realistic most companies things
they get a data think it's very classic
to say oh let's try to have an automatic
system to tell us I don't know how many
sales we're going to make how many you
know things we need to buy for our
inventory or and and I think the step to
say okay we have some data we would like
to predict this we would like to and
actually creating a model and putting it
in prediction that's the thing we're
trying to make a simple as possible and
and so I think it's I believe it can be
used in many many places and if we make
the two simple enough
then somebody that has no idea about
very till knowledge about machine
learning can just you know put the data
into our system train something deploy
it to the cloud putting into production
and to just work and and then and then
they can be the first step for this
person to have a machine learning system
running and then if you actually had
value to whatever the goal is they can
think more when we make it more
elaborate things so so really my goal is
to make this first step as easy as
possible so that people don't get
discouraged because it can be a bit
frightening see how I have to learn
statistics I have trained you know this
seems all complicated I don't even know
what the probability is
just got like hundreds thousands of
results but you don't even know her yes
yes and and there's a number of people
going to boot camps and think like that
shows show the neither for for such -
will I believe well thanks for talking
with me at the end thanks for watching